I challenged a thousand people to Photoshop this image,
an idea that's completely original. And I didn't steal from small time streamer,
Ludwig. Uh, so don't even look into that. Those are fake allegations,
you know, all that kind of stuff. Hold on, let me, sorry.
Let me get on y'all's level. Okay. Sorry. Tall guy problems over here. Uh,
let's bring up the subreddit showy guys.
It is a sub Reddit day guys copies. I'll underscore GG that's copies,
LNG port GG join the small club. Honestly,
it's a small club of privileged people right now who Photoshop this image.
So we're going to see what you guys yeah,
highest voted mean at the end of this wins platinum award and a
feature in next Saturday, this video,
I will also be selecting my personal favorite to also receive platinum. Okay.
If it's terrible, if it's good, whatever,
anything that makes me laugh and then finally stayed to the end because I'm
going to be announcing next week's challenge.
So if you want to win imaginary internet points,
that don't matter to anyone else,
but about a thousand people who know this thing exists, Hey,
you've come to the right place. Love go to the subreddit guys. Uh, honestly,
we're going pretty fast. A thousand members already.
We need to bump those numbers up 10,000 would be nice. Uh, but you know,
we're growing. We just started last week. Okay. Give me cut. Cut me some Slack.
So let's get into it. First meeting.
Yes.
Coffee Zilla. After missing an upload. Hey man, no, this is not gonna happen,
guys. This is never going to happen. I honestly,
I saw always Mark. I don't know if you guys saw this guy, a friend of mine.
He recently shaved his head and it's not a good luck.
I really joined his stream and I realized immediately this cannot happen to me.
So we are not going to be missing an upload daily,
YouTube all the way through January, maybe February. We'll see,
but not going to happen. So I gave that gold. Yes. Cause I'm a,
I'm a giving man next meme. By the way,
some of these means if it doesn't have the Photoshop damage in it,
it's technically not up for competition.
But I thought we just look at the memes of the subreddit anyways. Okay.
The story I tell.
What actually happened.
Pina is like stabbing a Teddy bear and he's on Joe Rogan.
The next day being like Joe,
it was eight feet tall and it was about to kill me until I got it.
Okay. I guess that's a chuckle I'll up vote that I not, you know,
a lot of memes that are not part of the competition.
This is the first thing actually. I learned about my audience.
Y'all don't listen.
That's number one is that these are irrelevant beams.
I'm pretty good. Honestly spoken like a true laptop, lifestyle millionaire.
A 30 year Harvard education. This is worthless.
Yeah.
That's what Caleb Maddix believes.
So what a lot of these guys believe they're like 30 years at Harvard.
It's a waste of time. It's why would you even do that? I mean,
it reminds me of this stuff, dude. It's like, it's not just Kayla Maddox.
Who's pushing this whack idea.
Obsolete ideal is go to school, get a job, work hard, save money.
Robert Kiyosaki.
Terrible idea. Don't listen to that guy.
The most absolute idea is to get a job guys, Hey, you don't need a job.
You can chill gold. And so get rigid,
vice like Robert Kiyosaki guys sell for MLMs.
Do that guys try that on for size, greatest opportunity of our era. So, uh,
gave that gold and I'll go ahead and give that enough Toke. Alright, next meme.
Business. Okay. Again, not relevant to the competition, but okay. That's fine.
Business gurus.
Be like having a stable nine to five job that Robert Kiyosaki hustling
24 seven and not actually making money. I'll take it
all up about it. Give it gold. Uh, see I'm a generous, you know,
dictator over here in the coffees, Dilla, Gigi sobriety, you got to join guys.
Cause I'm very nice to people. Next meme, top tips,
not relevant in many of the youngsters asked me I became so successful.
So here are my top tips. Buy a big house to impress investment bankers.
But for investment bankers.
Get investment bankers drunk, learn insight, information off junk bankers.
Trade-off insight information. Very simple. Good, good advice.
Actually not the first time we've had pretty good advice on this.
Separate it so far, the real pandemic at home.
Nice. Okay. You get gold for that. Me mom, can I get a Harvard education?
Mom, you can have a Harvard education at home. The Harvard education at home.
It's kind of true. Isn't it, man? Uh,
this is the new they're pitching themselves. Harvard educated.
It's like these guys are snake oil salesman. This is not even close.
It's not even close. This is like, how Ameesha is. He went to Harvard, X,
Harvard, X. Not the same thing guys.
Not the same long time. No. See friend. I haven't seen in years.
MI pyramid scheme. Yeah.
This kind of hits close to home.
But if you ever get a text or Facebook messenger,
it's usually Facebook messenger out of the blue.
Don't respond from someone you haven't seen. They're like, Hey Dan,
so nice to see you done it a long time. No. See,
got a crazy business opportunity.
I really want to talk to you about got time for coffee. No,
you only got time for coffees a lot next meme. Okay.
Finally, someone uses a picture of me, but it's the wrong picture of me.
You had your green screen material and did you.
A circle of me? I don't know what this kind of, but it is.
Okay. First Photoshop, whatever.
When Steven said get free gold from posting on his Reddit. He minutes.
The greatest opportunity of our era. True guys. True.
Actually I didn't mean that anyone who joined would get free gold,
but that's how everybody interpreted it.
I meant everybody who is on the Reddit at the time of me putting up that video
got free gold, but everyone came looking for free gold. So I ended up, uh,
scamming you. I don't know, pause to say it.
I tried to give a lot of free gold away, but nonetheless,
if you actually go to my subreddit right now, the number one, uh, top,
top rated thing.
Is in Pete's coffee.
When you post it.
[Inaudible] separate at three days ago and didn't get the gold that was
promised. I did a promise code away to everybody. I don't think I did.
I was trying to say that everyone who is on the separate at got free gold and it
was going to become harder to get over time. But I okay. I scammed you guys.
What can I say? Everyone came to the, to the subreddit, like, uh,
the seagulls from finding Nemo, boomer reference Mike, Mike
[inaudible] anyway, what's the meme. Uh,
but didn't get the gold that was promised.
I was a businessman doing business guys.
He got it through the business to get the subreddit followers.
That's all of that. It is in fact, look here.
It's a new competition for you guys to get gold because the current offers off
the table. Now, if you want to get gold, if you bring in three friends,
you get gold. If you have three people in your downline,
and if those three people also get three people, they get gold.
If your three friends do that, you get platinum. That's an announcement. Hey,
we're a pyramid scheme. Now that would be really funny. So get three friends in.
If you could prove it and you can prove that those three friends got three
friends to get platinum. That's it? That's it. That's how it's done.
Announcing it right now. And don't worry. You won't get scammed.
Remember how I did the last giveaway? So don't worry about that.
Never scammed anybody in my life. Oh,
they actually used the thing they use the green screen.
I didn't even notice 25. Upvotes okay. Uh,
did that beat the other guy? No, though.
Guy who actually did the thing.
Okay. All right.
Oh, here we go. Coffee Zilla got a P.
This is what I'm talking about. Yes,
they did the thing. Copies of, look out a PhD and fakers.
They use the green screen. Beautiful ma. Wow. I love it. Dreams.
PhD, Harvard, astrophysics. Yeah. Guys. I,
I have an announcement to make I'm the secret expert astrophysicist he was
talking about. I'm an expert in statistics and he didn't cheat guys.
He didn't cheat. Uh, yeah. Nice. Clever used,
uh, you know, use the call back. Is that the top voted one right now?
That's out. I think that's the highest upvoted one. So far 36 votes.
All right. Way to go. You're on your way to platinum. Sure.
Uh, you, whatever. I don't know what that username is. Next meme guys.
It was hard to find a picture of Dan Penia, smiling,
coming to the sup to support your favorite YouTuber coming on the sub to receive
a gold award. Wow. He actually is smiling.
I think that is the first time I've seen Dan Pena smile. You know,
a lot of dead Piney means he's a very well guy. I've got to give it to him.
He's one of the most memorable gurus for sure. And I did give you gold. Okay.
Notice that I'm not a con man. I came through on my promise. Okay.
Came here for the Reddit gold. That's it. And as you can see,
not a condom and I gave you Reddit gold. Okay.
Cause right now people are demanding that I scammed everybody. Dude.
I seriously gave gold to as many people as I could.
Which guys too many of you posted? What could I say? I demand. Copy to be.
I investigated by himself on his own channel for not giving me the gold on the
meme. I posted three days ago. Where's my gold seafood scammer of the year.
Time. It's actually pretty good.
I just noticed he used the thing five upvotes too bad, buddy.
Naka and get gold this time. No, you know what? Actually,
since you actually did the thing, Hey, I'm going to give you gold. Boom.
How dare you slander this great man. True. Also gold.
Thank you for defending my honor.
Appreciate you defending my honor. Their gold, a tough choice.
What do you choose? Joining Harvard joining maximum wage.
I can't decide guys. What do you think we should do? Entrepreneur?
Join my team for $20 and be your own boss to everybody on
Instagram with like four in their bio or entrepreneur in their bio.
They don't own what they say they own. Please guys.
Don't fall for this stuff. There's gold. And then there's maximum gold.
Real gold copies. Oh, pretty good. Well, Hey sir,
you've got real cold right there. Fool's gold.
Maximum comedy gold worth more than 30 years at Harvard.
Oh yeah. That's a, that's going to be a meme forever.
I feel like I have a feeling. This is going to turn into people. Making of me.
We use for being a habit and for having a large head IDK copies of at
2021 therapist copies Ella with glasses. Is it real? He can't hurt you.
Coffee's Zillow with glasses. Hey, Hey man,
you don't need to stretch out my head. That's rude. That's already offensive.
This is fake news. I don't believe this. I don't know where you got this image,
but uh, I do not wear glasses. Perfect. 20, 20 vision.
And don't let anyone tell you guys otherwise please coffees.
Exposing upcoming fake gurus for the first time. Oh gee. Fake gurus. First time.
Uh, yeah man. Sometimes I do look at these like new guys coming up and I'm like,
how do you do not see where this leads? It's a bad,
it's a bad disliked decision. Not because of me,
but just look at the future of like,
you want to be tight Lopez when you grow up, who grows up and be like, Hey,
I want to be like Dan Locke. I don't, I don't know.
I don't know who looks up to these guys copies of like taking a dump on his King
size toilet, $10 million studio stuff. What is this?
What is this Photoshop?
You couldn't crop it in to make it seem like I just didn't have no feet.
You wouldn't understand. And then by the way,
okay, that was all fine. Fun and games. But then the comments isn't that?
A normal size toilet with a Hobbit on it. You're right.
I need to slap whoever wrote the title for spreading fake news. What is this?
Okay, let me say something guys. I'm sorry. I got to address this right now.
Okay. This is, this is downright offensive.
And to put this to bed once and for all,
this has all been fake news this whole time. The truth is guys.
I'm not that short. Okay. Um, I'm actually pretty tall.
My doctor badgered me the other day. He said I'm one Rogan tall. Maybe even too,
like I'm like one to two Rogan's tall. And um, yeah,
I don't want to be made fun of it for it anymore.
I know the Hobbit meme was funny, but uh, it's not funny anymore.
Okay. I'm outta here trying to fight the fake gurus and uh,
y'all are fighting yellow bullying me and I don't appreciate. All right,
guys that about does it the highest rated meme that used the challenge was this
one copies. I've got a PhD in fake gurus dreams, PhD, Harvard, astrophysicist.
Congratulations.
You're the first person to get platinum on this subreddit and uh, yeah.
Hats off to you, sir. Congratulations. It's a special day. Okay.
Gold and platinum. That's it. It's a big, big honor. Okay.
The next person, I guess runner up. I would have to say this one.
Coffee's after missing an upload, sir, you also get platinum.
Thanks for playing.
This is why you always have to just try because you never know if you're going
to watch, you're going to win. Okay. Here on copies, elite,
easy to get gold and platinum, especially if you recruit through friends.
So guys, thanks for playing. Thanks for joining. Uh, hope you enjoyed it.
You know, I, I guess back in my day I had Saturday morning cartoons.
You guys have lazy. Saturday's lazy red. Saturday's good. Trade-off I would say,
uh, so thanks for watching. Hope you enjoyed before you go.
We've got a new challenge for the subreddit day. Sweet guys.
It's not a meme now we're getting our musical talents engaged.
All you have to do is create the new lazy Saturday theme song, guys,
the highest upvoted theme song. Uh, and it has to be a safer work,
you know, fun, good for the video,
but it will become our theme song and we'll also get platinum.
So submit your theme songs in the sub.
Guys we'll have a little a form for it or whatever. Go ahead, sign up.
Who knows? You could win. You could win gold.
You could win platinum and better yet.
You could win the love and support of a bunch of internet strangers.
Thanks for watching.
See you the next one.